I'm a big fan of Disney's Melania I love
the characters the music and the
animation as I'm sure you'll know from
my other videos about the film but the
movie we know and love about the
fearless future chief and her amusing
dynamic with an egotistical demigods
started out life very differently
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal
how the trickster demigod Maui very
nearly ruins the delightfully refreshing
story of Moana by the way I've got a
great giveaway to win this gorgeous art
of Moana hardback book I'll be running
that on my mallanna deleted scenes video
so make sure you subscribe and turn on
your notifications for flicks in the
city so you don't miss it and I'll add a
link to the video here when it's ready
quick warning if you haven't seen Moana
yet I will be talking spoilers and
discussing alternative endings for the
movie in this video if that's a problem
you can check out my spoiler free
milliner review here and watch this
video after you've had a chance to see
the film when Moana directors Ron
Clements and John Musker decided they
wanted to make a movie based in the
Pacific Islands they began by
researching the mythology of the region
in particular the legends of the demigod
Maui indeed the original title of the
film was going to be Mikey Maui it was
going to adapt the number of Maui myths
into a brand new story that focused
principally on his character one of the
main legends they plan to use involved a
sidekick female character who asked
Maori to help rescue her lover who'd
been kidnapped
however after directors Ron Clements and
John Wesker traveled to the Pacific to
learn more about the culture they found
out their original idea was rather
stereotyped during their visit they
learned about oceanic peoples very
strong connection to the sea and their
shared history of navigation so they
decided the story should focus more
significantly on that on their return
Clements and Musker tossed out the
mighty Maui concept in Reverse the two
character roles making Maui decide kick
and Moana the lead character their idea
was that the film should concentrate on
being a discovery of who you really are
and they envisaged Moana and Maui as a
kind of True Grit style Odd Couple as
the filmmakers went about enhancing
miners role in the movie they also
reduced Maui's role however they got to
a point where they decided they needed a
little more balance for example you're
welcome was originally going to be Moana
songs the idea being that when she
Maui on his island he would be kind of
miserable so to raise his spirits Murano
is seeing the song to remind him of all
his incredible exploits in the end of
course the soul was reworked into a
fantastic dragging session for Maui
about how amazing he thinks he is with
Dwayne Johnson giving a brilliant
rendition of you're welcome in the final
film and to ensure that Maui still made
an impact as a character the demigod
also went through a number of redesigns
initially Maui was going to be much
smaller and rather a disappointment to
Moana when she first met him he was also
going to be balls and more of a grumpy
curmudgeon in many early versions
however after discussions with Pacific
Islanders the filmmakers found as a Maui
of legend was a much larger than life
character with a thick mane of hair
according to the movies head of story
David Pimentel the feedback from
Disney's oceanic story trust was that
Maui needs to be a hero
almost like Superman and in particular
Maui had to be given a lot more hair as
that's the source of much of his
legendary power now one of the most
beautiful and touching moments in Moana
happens towards the end of the film when
Moana parts the sea and walks up to the
car to restore her missing heart instead
of a villain being defeated what we see
is a peaceful resolution and redemption
foot to car and of course a triumph for
Moana but in previous versions of the
script this wasn't what happened rather
it was Maui who dominated the end of the
story completely overshadowing marinas
journey and achievement in one alternate
ending well Ana had to dive underwater
to put the heart back in the car and
while doing this she became trapped and
she was only saved when Maui pulled up
the island with his fish hook and
another alternate ending had marijuana
and Maui fighting to car together but it
was Maui who was mostly responsible for
defeating the lava demon quite late in
the day these endings were eventually
rejected as they diminished mallanna's
achievement and made Maui the hero of
Moana
story the final ending I thought was
much more satisfying so what do you
think about the changes to Maui in
Disney's Moana do you think it was
better to Moana to take the lead role or
would you like to see more Maui in the
final movie and are there any maui
legends you think should have been
included I'd love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this make sure to hit that like button
and subscribe for lots more of my Disney
videos including an in-depth look at all
the deleted scenes and songs in moaña
and also all the Easter eggs in the
movie coming up shortly I'll have new
videos on Beauty and the Beast and an
art of one a book giveaway Capel click
here to check those out thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers